Thank you Verni, you've entered the Estia Familia
What
's wrong?
It's nice It
's kind of strange When we met, I didn't think it would turn out like this That's right I didn't think it was
me ah ah ah ah
That's right, but after that, you've helped me many times, from
your precious familia to your seat in the parliament, and you've come to help me in a big game.
I was able to become a proper adventurer because of riri, who taught me things Always be by
my side,
my first
companion Oh, oh, oh
, and
God, God found me  God gave me a place to
belong to a lot of people since I came to Rio.
I'm just getting it from everyone, isn't
it okay?
[Applause]
[Music]
Yes in Komemura